i'll be fine
sir touch your hair one last time jeffy
yeah
touch your head one last time
yeah yeah thanks traffic
you've done this before
filled with confidence
teacher jeffy
all right
why do i feel two at once what's that
yeah falling down
we can start to see your scalp oh great
how's it look
you look amazing thank you
so how long has it been in the making
long
what do you think jeremy
i'm excited
i'll make an appointment for you okay
where
what are your thoughts on traffic's
haircutting skills yeah i don't know
pretty dodge
like fully manhandling your head
yeah i'm feeling totally violated
hey nathan how's it looking
are you guys doing the top yet
satisfaction
all right let's make it even true
huh
this is mr wu's iphone
guys i needed to see the head cutting
action
all right let's go
it's off center i know right what the
hell
wow guys
is that number two
you have to be very very stupid okay
okay push my head
around all right
i'm good
daniel i'm pretty sure you can hold it
against the skin
yeah you can push harder yeah you can
hold it against the skin that's why they
have the flat beard
just watch the ears
oh this side's getting
getting pretty bad
sorry
okay
hey there's a tuft of hair sticking up
here
you tell me daniel i got no idea
didn't think you could get any better
but i guess i was wrong
oh you can push a little harder it's all
right
i don't want to lie
it's getting pretty bad
around
no it's because of the sun
can you see it now
oh my god
i love that surprise
did you see what sanji said no he said
right
i wish i knew what you were
videos
your thing's still one
go round it
hey look he's actually
as well
see
sorry mr wu your head's very nicely
shaped thank you annie it's a lot coming
for you
hey how many people are back there doing
this seriously
i'm sure there's a joke in here about
how many prefixes it takes to shave
ahead
but
i'll work on it
is
there we go
it's all right
daniel you're good to go
is
okay
i think you're done
what a good job
we
jokes
oh my god
go that way
to the middle
oh there we go
actually quite nice
yeah here we go here we
you go like a monk
thanks